bueno
[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con el mes de
marzo hemos presenciado masivas
protestas en diferentes partes del mundo
contra la violencia de género y por las
reivindicaciones de los derechos de las
mujeres desde todos los ámbitos de la
vida se están levantando para exigir que
dejemos de ser tratadas como ciudadanas
de segunda clase nos acompaña desde
buenos aires de florencia paterno doctor
en ciencias sociales y socióloga
especializada en estudios laborales y
estudios de género florencia gracias por
acompañarnos y usted es una experta en
economía feminista porque necesitamos no
sólo entender este concepto sino
aplicarlo cuando las mujeres tienen más
protagonismo en la economía llega el
desarrollo aumenta la productividad los
sistemas económicos se fortalecen
si buen día claramente gracias por la
entrevista y si tenemos que pensar en
que después de la pandemia una de las
preguntas claves es qué tipo de
recuperación sostenible estamos hablando
si las mujeres no están incluidas o bien
si las mujeres siguen siendo el corazón
del trabajo no registrado si la pandemia
sigue mostrando justamente que la crisis
de los cuidados se hizo o se hizo en
evidencia justamente con una
contundencia muy fuerte entonces esta
sobrecarga de trabajos domésticos y de
cuidados no remunerados mostraron
y los malabares que hicieron las mujeres
para compatibilizar responsabilidades
laborales cuidado de niñez limpieza y
aseo de los hogares esto se mostró de
manera muy fuerte durante la pandemia
y es que si aquí el tema de la autonomía
económica y monetaria es clave para
tener un mundo más igualitario que
realmente respalde la labor de las
mujeres que realmente reconozca su papel
social
usted lo estaba diciendo desde las
tareas de cuidado y el trabajo doméstico
hasta las labores en lugares como las
empresas al final las tareas de casa no
son más que una explotación
claramente es eso que llaman amor es
trabajo no pago como dicen las banderas
y los y las diferentes reivindicaciones
que se vieron en el 8 de marzo el 8 de
marzo también muestra eso cómo logramos
no solamente visibilizar el trabajo no
remunerado sino también reconocerlo
redistribuirlo y cuáles son las
inversiones que se van a hacer en los
diferentes gobiernos y pensamos los
números en américa latina' de cara a la
recuperación económica esa recuperación
económica no puede pensar solamente en
el mundo productivo sino que tiene que
pensar justamente en cómo se va a pensar
la reorganización social de los cuidados
y qué tipo de inversión se va a hacer en
materia de infraestructura de cuidados
en materia de políticas concretas de
cuidados creo que ese es el gran desafío
y que se mostran las calles en el último
8 de marzo mire florencia y además un
gran origen de la desigualdad en la
actividad económica es la maternidad
seguimos pensando que criar hijos es
responsabilidad de la madre y que el
padre como no puede parir ni dar teta
tiene licencia para seguir creciendo
profesionalmente mientras la mujer se
queda en casa rezagada eso
cambiar
exactamente hay que revisar las
licencias por paternidad
hay que revisar también esta extensión
que se dio en materia de virtualización
empleo remoto y teletrabajo pensemos
quienes pueden seguir cumpliendo con
jornadas laborales ininterrumpidas en
sus hogares mientras continúan
modalidades de teletrabajo de empleo
remoto hay que revisar fuertemente eso
porque se ha extendido justamente en el
marco la pandemia y todo indica que
muchas empresas van a optar por estas
modalidades entonces creo que hay
también hay un gran desafío sobre todo
en los roles y la división sexual del
trabajo al interior de los hogares como
bien vos decías y también está el tema
del protagonismo en las empresas
mire vemos anuncios llenos de orgullo
porque las compañías anuncian por
ejemplo que tienen llamas deseos mujeres
o avances en la paridad pero el problema
que yo veo es que se anuncian estos
temas como si fueran una gran novedad
casi como si tuviéramos que agradecer
por los nombramientos que realmente
deberían ser un paisaje común esto es
qué opina
sí creo que estas narrativas que se
construyen alrededor de ese itinerario
individual de una trayectoria laboral
exitosa de una mujer como líder de una
empresa o como sede de una empresa bueno
muestran también esa lectura más
individualista y lo que vemos cuando
analizamos las cifras incluso si
analizamos los últimos datos de la cepal
que muestran que durante la pandemia se
han perdido justamente una década en
materia de la participación laboral de
las mujeres en la economía y que
justamente la recuperación va a implicar
remontar esos números entonces no
podemos analizar la llegada de una mujer
al director de una empresa como el
síntoma de un avance en materia de
igualdad creo que hay que seguir mirando
la segmentación y la segregación que se
sigue marcando en ciertos sectores por
ejemplo el sector servicios y los
sectores más afectados durante estos
últimos meses gracias a ustedes
florencia somos necesarias no lo
suficientemente valoradas siga con
nosotros en france 24
[Música]